- [Voiceover] Ethene, C2H4, molar mass
of 28.1 grams per mole, may be prepared
by the dehydration of ethanol,
C2H5OH, molar mass 46.1 grams
per mole, using a solid catalyst.
A setup for the lab synthesis is shown
in the diagram above.
The equation for the dehydration reaction
is given below.
So, we have the ethanol,
and then in the presence
of a catalyst, we're going
to yield, after our reaction,
some ethene and some
water, and then we have
some metrics on the actual reaction.
A student added a 0.200 gram
sample of ethanol, this is ethanol,
C2H5OH, to a test tube,
using the setup shown above.
So this is the glass wool with ethanol,
so the ethanol is right over here.
There's a solid catalyst right over there.
The student heated the test tube gently
with a Bunsen burner until
all of the ethanol evaporated,
and gas generation stopped.
So, here you see the heating,
all of the ethanol here
evaporates, the gas generation stops.
When the reaction stopped,
the volume of gas collected
was 0.0854 liters
at 0.822 atmospheres
and 305 Kelvin.
The vapor pressure of water
at 305 Kelvin is 35.7 torr.
So, what you have is, in the
presence of the catalyst,
you have the ethanol, it's going to react,
it's a dehydration, it's
a dehydration reaction
right over here, so
you're going to produce
ethene and water, and
so, you cool it down,
and so the ethene gets
captured at the top,
it's going to be in a gaseous state.
The water, it's going to be water vapor,
but then, of course, once
you've cooled it down,
you're going to have
liquid, you're going to have
liquid water here as well.
So, let's try to answer their questions.
Calculate the number of moles of ethene,
one, that are actually
produced in the experiment
and measured in the gas collection tube,
and two, that would be produced
if the dehydration reaction
went to completion.
Part b, calculate the percent yield
of ethene in the experiment.
All right, so let's tackle part one.
Let's tackle part one first, and so,
somehow we have to figure out the,
we have to figure out the actual moles
produced in the experiment and measured
in the gas collection tube.
So, what do they tell us here?
They said until all of
the ethanol evaporated
and gas generation stopped.
When the reaction stopped,
the volume of gas,
so this volume of gas, so
this is our volume of gas
right over here, that's
where our ethene is,
our volume of gas was
0.0854 liters,
so we underline that,
at 0.822 atmospheres,
so that's the total pressure there.
The temperature is 305 Kelvin,
and then they give us the vapor pressure
of water is 35.7, at 305 Kelvin,
is 35.7 torr.
The vapor pressure of water,
you could view that as a partial pressure
of water, and the reason
why that's useful is
the partial pressure of water plus
the partial pressure of the ethene
is going to add up to
the total pressure here.
And so, we can use that information
to figure out the partial
pressure of the ethene.
So, the partial pressure of the ethene.
And if we know the partial
pressure of the ethene,
well, then we can use the Ideal Gas Law
to figure out how many moles of ethene,
how many moles of ethene are
actually right over here.
How can we do that?
Well, just a little reminder
of the Ideal Gas Law.
We have pressure, and
if we're talking about
one particular thing, here we'd be talking
about the partial pressure of ethene,
times volume, they give us
the volume right over here,
is equal to the number of
moles times the gas constant
times the temperature.
Well, we have the pressure,
we have-- or, we'll be able
to figure it out, we have the volume,
we have the gas constant.
You don't have to memorize these things.
Right over here, I copied and pasted
what they give you at the
front of the actual AP exam,
so that you don't have to
memorize these constants
and things like that.
So, we have the gas
constant, and then we have it
in different units, depending on which one
we want to use, and then, of course,
the temperature, they give it to us.
It is 305 Kelvin.
So, if we want to figure
out the number of moles,
right over here, you can divide both sides
by RT, and so you could say n is equal to,
is equal to R, sorry, n is equal to,
we divide both sides,
if we divide both sides
by RT, we're going to get PV, and I'll say
the partial pressure of ethene,
times the volume, times the volume,
over, over R times T
over R times T.
And so, let's figure out
everything over here.
So, what is going to be the
partial pressure of the ethene?
Well, the pressure of,
the partial pressure
of the ethene is going to be equal
to the total pressure, the total pressure
minus the partial pressure,
or you could say the vapor
pressure, of the water,
the partial pressure of, the
partial pressure of the water.
So, this is going to be equal to,
our total pressure is 0.822 atmospheres,
0.822 atmospheres.
Now, what's the pressure of,
what's the partial pressure of the water?
They tell us the vapor pressure
of water at 305 Kelvin is 35.7 torr.
Well, they gave us the total
pressure in atmospheres,
so we have to convert
from, we have to convert
from torrs to atmospheres
if we want to stay
in atmospheres.
So I'll do it over here.
So, the pressure, the pressure
of, the partial pressure
of the water is equal to 35.7 torr,
which is a unit of pressure.
But if we want to convert
it to atmospheres,
once again, you don't have
to memorize these things.
They give it to you on the test.
They tell us, one atmosphere is 760 torr.
So, we wanna get rid of the torr.
We wanna get rid of the
torr, and we want it
in terms of atmospheres,
so one atmosphere is
760 torr, so this is going to be equal
to 35.7 divided by 760.
So it's this is the total pressure,
minus the partial pressure of the water.
Let's see, the partial
pressure of the water,
let me figure this out.
It is going to be 35.7 torr
times one atmosphere
for every 760 torr, so
I'll just divide by 760,
divided by 760, is equal to,
and I have three significant digits here.
So, 0.0470.
0.0470.
So this is going to be
0.0470 atmospheres.
So, let me write that down.
So, the total pressure
minus the partial pressure
of the water,
0.0470 atmospheres,
is going to be equal to,
is going to be equal to--
So, let me just take my--
Well, I could just make that a negative,
and then add it to the total pressure,
so, plus, plus .822
or 0.822 is going to be equal to...
So, the partial pressure of our ethene,
three significant digits here,
is going to be 775, 0.775.
So, 0.775.
And so now, we can substitute that in.
We know everything to figure
out the number of moles.
N is going to be equal to 0.775.
The units here are atmospheres;
we can always check to make sure
that we get that right, atmospheres.
Times our volume.
Well, they tell us our volume.
It's 0.0854 liters,
0.0854 liters,
and then we divide that by RT.
Now, which version of R do we use?
Well, we're dealing with atmospheres,
moles, and Kelvin, so we could use,
we could use this right over here.
If we had converted everything to torr,
we would use this constant.
So, our R is going to be
0.08206.
They're giving us more significant digits.
Doesn't hurt to use
them, but later we have
to just realize that we're gonna convert
to only three significant digits,
because that's the minimum,
that's what we have.
These are three, three, this
is more than three signifi--
This is four significant digits.
But let's just make
sure the units work out.
So, this is going to be--
So this is the units here
are liters times atmosphere,
and so those will cancel
with these, divided by,
we have to remember this is
in, this is in the denominator
right over here, divided
by moles times Kelvin,
and we multiply that
times the temperature,
which is 305 Kelvin, 305 Kelvin.
And we'll see, we could see that, well,
this atmospheres is going to cancel
with that atmospheres,
that liters is going
to cancel with that liters,
this Kelvin is going
to cancel with that Kelvin,
and so, in the denominator,
you're dividing by moles, so that's gonna
be the same thing as just
having moles as your units.
And so, this is all going to be equal to,
we deserve a little bit of a,
we deserve a little
bit of a drumroll here.
This is equal to--
So, 0.775 atmospheres
times .0854 liters
divided by .08206,
so that gets us that,
and then we're going to divide by 305.
We still have that in the denominator,
divided by 305,
is equal to, and if we do
three significant digits,
it's 0.00264.
So this is approximately, I could say,
0.00264
264 moles.
Did I write that right?
I have a bad memory.
0.00264, yeah,
I rounded down to 264 moles.
And there you have it, that's part one.
The number of moles of ethene
that are actually produced
in the experiment and measured
in the gas collection tube.